[Music]
so today i think it would be good to um
to honor dr john chang he was the doctor
during the taiwanese church shooting at
laguna woods he's the guy who actually
went and tackled the shooter oh my god
i'm able to subdue uh the shooter
because of him wow also the only guy
that died yo dude i heard that the whole
church once that happened
just for that second they were able to
like dock pile and then they [ __ ]
like they hog title with extension cords
yeah with extension cords they thought
they moved fast he saved everyone's life
yeah because he had they were able to
take the two guns off of him uh about
that guy are they they're taiwanese yeah
yeah have you ever seen taiwanese
politics
i don't think like they started
fighting oh is that the word they're
like
they probably had experience from that
already
so the minute they felt conflict oh this
is [ __ ] easy
i was wondering like who knows how to
hog tie people but that's not common
knowledge thing yeah the tower
you'll see guys pick up chairs and throw
it across the room and a guy actually
did that nice a guy one guy actually
threw a chair from experience
i'm not even kidding like that really
happened which which taiwanese martial
art is this like chair throwing
parliament
taiwanese parliament
but yeah the uh they were able to subdue
them and all of the victims i believe
that were shot were like between the
ages of like 60 or something like all
like
even the shooter was like hella old he's
like 68 or something like that did this
say did they release what the conflict
was yeah so yeah he's he's a vegas
resident that grew up in taiwan but he's
a mainland chinese that grew up in
taiwan and then he had this hate toward
taiwanese people
and china people a little differently
yeah yeah because they're less
you know but than yeah i thought like he
had a conflict with someone at church no
he doesn't you know like
how come you don't set up chairs like
you know i'm gonna go shoot everybody
you know drove from vegas yeah he didn't
even know anyone there and he he
basically like ate their potluck hung
out with them for a couple of hours and
then that full super glued like the
doors oh my god
locked him up and then he started his
[ __ ] shooting did he just choose a
random church or he had like a special
seems like
because he told them that he had been
there before he's like i've been to this
church but all of the long-time
parishioners of that church were like we
don't know this dude
and you know it's pretty easy to know
who goes to your church if you if that's
your church and especially if you're
that old yeah i bet he was a little
weird yeah even if someone comes in like
once or twice you know oh yeah that guy
came in uh in taiwan if you're not from
taiwan uh there's like a foreigner word
that's kind of derogatory what is it uh
why certain so it's like it's like say
like like gaijin right there that's like
that outsider yeah so it's like oh this
guy's not from here there's like a so
it's not gaijin's not derogatory oh this
one's a little bit derogatory okay yeah
it's because taiwanese no one do a press
so they press everyone they can
because for the longest time they were
oppressed
they don't think they're our country
that's why yeah other than the
the doctor was pretty much the guy i
saved the day five other people got
wounded what i didn't get is like this
dude
he hate like i i guess they're saying
that it was uh racially motive or like
hate motivated they're calling it a hate
crime because he hated taiwanese people
but he basically spent most of his life
life in taiwan but he's he was mad about
the recent tensions between china and
taiwan and i'm like what what makes you
[ __ ] think that going into a
taiwanese church is gonna stop taiwan
like taiwan's gonna look at this and
they're gonna be like oh my god you're
right you're so right we'll be china
yeah we're yeah
on top of that they're she's shooting
americans exactly they're not even like
taiwanese
taiwan are expensive so like you know i
feel like
you're trying to save some money yeah
and you can't take guns you know
probably it's just a market manipulation
i mean this is no different than like
the crazy crackheads that are punching
asian grandmas thinking that that's
going to stop covet or whatever it's
like the [ __ ]
this is crazy i think it's no different
from any demonstration that's not
directly tackling your adversary like
you're not like if you taiwan nor china
are gonna look at any outside example
and go we'll consider that in our next
polit political like talks like no they
don't give [ __ ] like if you want to take
down china you have to directly take
down china like you're not going to take
him down in america that was actually
like he's shooting like taiwanese
ambassadors or exactly it's like no
you're going to go after the most
vulnerable
and they're us citizens yeah
and i [ __ ] up did the doctor take like
a bunch of gunshots
i i don't know how many shots he took
that's that's seriously like brave stuff
because like if someone came to my
church
and like i usually sit in the back
because that's where all the cool people
sit yeah yeah so like i'd probably be
one of the first
like the targets right yeah well then
that's what i would do is like as soon
as i heard something
like i'd be gone i thought i saw walter
nah he just took off
he left a while ago yeah and so if i for
this guy's mental like state to be like
i'm gonna go hit him first yeah like
that wouldn't even cross my mind
that's gangster yeah that i i'd be like
hey do you think this chair would like
stop the bullet yeah nah play it you
think you'll see me run like i think
running would be better
like that's what go through my mind
seriously
it's hard to imagine yourself in that
situation where you would like jump a
gunman you know yeah
and it said that the doctor he he knew
martial arts as well
like uh
he was probably the more capable not the
one that could catch bullets apparently
he needs to learn from wemo are there
any martial arts that are bullet
specific yeah join my academy there remo
williams he learned from this korean
dude
um technically he was a white guy but he
had this
and then he taught him how to dodge
bullets it's because you have to hear
the tendons and the finger pulling and
then he would yes he would you never saw
remove that was a great great
documentary rip fred ward
yeah there were several installations
yeah dude oh it was great but the korean
guy played by the you know like oz
amazing your best korean depiction his
accent was actually decent it wasn't
good it was just decent it was a mixture
of chinese and korean
oh but yeah what happened to all the um
all the martial arts studios that are
ran by white guys that pretend to be
asian
like do they all disappear i think
they're all just closer to the midwest
now oh
or madojo ousted them all i know i think
they transitioned to mma oh really yeah
because you know honestly if i walked
into uh like a taekwondo studio and the
master was white i'd walk right back out
yeah it's just it's just like if you
guys have kids and your son goes to a
basketball camp and it's run by a korean
dude you'd be like what's this
you're going to walk
no all right you're going to walk right
out did you even play high school ball
yeah yeah oh junior high okay cool yeah
you know i think it hits one of them the
coach is like five two and you're like
nah bro
nah
i i think it's so like you know and then
if if a korean opens a tecuno studio and
he might suck
but he's korean it's authentic yeah
they're gonna go to him they feel like
they're in it you know
he's not a player anymore he's a coach
now yeah exactly right that's why he
sucks yeah he's a mexican guy
and um but you'll eat korean food by
mexico exactly so here's the thing with
mexicans that's great
they don't culturally they don't want to
own businesses like i don't want to
worry about i want to stress about it
which is a great philosophy to have
right so koreans can koreans chinese
whoever japanese they can entrust
mexicans and teach them how to make
everything that's true you're not going
to have juan's korean barbecue
no one's going to go oh like on the yeah
even though juan makes all the korean
barbecue it makes it awesome
no one's going to go they never want to
backstab you and open across the street
yeah they'll never fire no chinese
because they'll learn everything and
then open up a restaurant they do that
currently they'll they'll bot they'll
buy into a korean franchise
a restaurant they'll learn everything
they'll they'll nix the franchise deal
and they'll in the same location open up
again under a new name you know what you
know what is happening though which is
sort of like a a lateral ballsy move is
most of the japanese food trucks are
owned by mexicans oh that's that's
that's smart that's like a little side
hack what's the japanese food truck any
of those uh the tapaniakis
oh
some some do like a fusion though like
i've seen a couple that are like keep
like hibachi but they also like you know
it's a mexican fusion things i'm like oh
that's another one plugs are their thing
though they started that [ __ ] they're
pretty freaking japanese is tapping yeah
i don't even know what that is the
[ __ ] girl who bought you girls
that's all you're doing
is it worth it that's steve aoki's dad
he's the one that made that [ __ ]
yeah you should go it's not even
japanese i want to go i want to check it
out i want them to [ __ ] art made by i
think it's steve aoki's dad that
invented all that rocky
mouth yeah
yeah i wanna put my shrimp in my mouth
they don't do all that that's not all
you want though yeah
they do it from the truck everyone's
standing outside
you're driving next to it he's in the
vodka
shoot that [ __ ] in your [ __ ] face
you